[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch rudi cerne für den sport mit
informationen von der nationalmannschaft
guten abend wer regiert künftig
deutschland auch heute gab es dazu
wichtige treffen
suche nach dem dreierbündnis die grünen
haben erstmals mit der union
sondierungsgespräche geführt fortsetzung
offen die physik nobelpreis für
klimaforscher sich auch der deutsche
klaus hasselmann wird ausgezeichnet für
seine modelle zum menschengemachten
klimawandel und enthüllungen eine
insiderin eine ehemalige facebook
mitarbeiterin erhebt schwere vorwürfe
gegen das soziale netzwerk
wir sind gespannt wie es weiter geht mit
diesem satz sprach csu-chef söder heute
wohl vielen aus der seele alle
potenziellen regierungspartner haben
jetzt paarweise miteinander gesprochen
als letztes am vormittag grüne und union
danach waren die chefs von cdu und csu
intensiv um weitere gespräche mit den
grünen die allerdings blieben
zurückhaltend aus berlin kam
hinterleitner
dass eure gelände in berlin ein
ideenlabor der energiewende schon mit
der wahl des ortes will die union wohl
die botschaft senden zukunft und klima
das sind auch unsere themen da geht was
gemeinsam mit den grünen die statements
der teilnehmer nach dem treffen heute
dann eher zurückhaltend bis vorsichtig
optimistisch klar ist in gerade
gesellschaftspolitischen bereichen
stehen unsere parteien er weiter
auseinander darüber haben wir auch
gesprochen was es für differenzen gibt
und in anderen bereichen gibt es
entsprechend auch gemeinsame anliegen
wie die modernisierung unseres landes
wird sondern einen guten austausch man
konnte in vielen gedanklich nummer an
2017 anknüpfen wo wir ja schon über
viele themen auch gemeinsam gesprochen
haben und
wir glauben dass ein solches bündnis
eine breite in der gesellschaft hat
die es wirklich möglich macht das land
in den nächsten jahren zu modernisieren
voranzubringen
inhaltliche unterschiede gebe es vor
allem bei den themen klima und migration
aber annäherung sei durchaus möglich
wenn alle bereit werden aufeinander
zuzugehen camp ist glaube ich große
chancen so ein gespräch fortzusetzen
sie hatten am sonntag gesagt wir hätten
lust auf mehr nach dem gespräch mit der
fdp ich fand das gespräch hat insofern
genauso oder noch spannender die fdp und
wir werden sicherlich jetzt die
gespräche insgesamt in den gremien
bewerten also nicht jedes gespräch
einzelner sondern auch im abgleich
dessen was möglich ist für eine nächste
regierung in deutschland es war das
letzte noch ausstehende zweiergespräch
wie erfolgreich das werben der union
heute wahr werden die kommenden tage
zeigen
fragen wir wieder unseren
hauptstadtkorrespondenten theo koll ihr
fazit nach dieser ersten
sondierungsrunde
nun wird es stimmt dass heute abend
erneut einer zeitung wesentliche punkte
des vertraulichen gesprächs
durchgestochen worden dann muss ich
ehrlich sagen war das der todesstoß für
sondierungsgespräche der union genannt
wurden am abend drei forderungen der
grünen die aufweichung des
eu-stabilitätspakts das ende des
verbrennungsmotors vor 2035 und eine
offenere
migrationspolitik damit wäre dann sowohl
die vertraulichkeit mit der fdp als auch
jetzt die mit den grünen gebrochen
worden dann kann man so sagte mir heute
jemand aus einem der sondiere teams mit
der union nicht mehr offen reden
inhaltlich war die union heute eher
demütig betonte wie sehr man an weiteren
gesprächen interessiert sein armin
laschet hat heute sogar noch eine
interessante trumpfkarte auf den tisch
gelegt nämlich den bundesrat viele
entscheidungen einer künftigen
koalitionsregierung brauchen ja die
zustimmung der länderkammer und da geht
auf absehbare zeit nichts ohne die union
habe da sie mich nach einem fazit
gefragt haben der mehrfache bruch der
vertraulichkeit die unions internen
kämpfe die vielfache parteiinterne
infragestellung von armin laschet all
das spricht gegen jamaika und dürfte mit
nochmals gestiegene wahrscheinlichkeit
zur ampel sondierung führen danke für
diese einschätzung theo koll war das
wie erleben junge abgeordnete den
koalitionspoker das ist gleich thema bei
zdf heute live zu gast sind zwei
parlamentarier von fdp und grünen um 19
uhr 30 in der zdf- heute- app und auf
unseren social media kanälen für cdu
chef armin laschet geht's karrieremäßig
gerade um alles oder nichts schon lange
hatte er angekündigt dass er auch wenn
er nicht kanzler wird in berlin bleibt
und sein amt als ministerpräsident von
nordrhein-westfalen ab gibt heute nun
hat er seiner partei in düsseldorf einen
nachfolger empfohlen hendrik höchst 46
jurist und bisher verkehrsminister in
nrw ralph goldmann
er soll der neue starke cdu mann in
nordrhein westfalen werden hendrik wüst
noch verkehrsminister in der
schwarz-gelben düsseldorfer koalition
armin laschet schlug ihn vor gut einer
stunde der fraktion und dem
parteivorstand vor unser land ist
vielfältig diese vielfalt ist unsere
stärke und unser schatz den vielfalt und
zusammenhalt hand in hand gehen
diesen zusammenhalt von land und leuten
fühle ich mich persönlich verpflichtet
hendrik wüst ist 46 jahre alt und stammt
aus dem münsterland seit 2005 gehörte
dem landtag an und war cdu
generalsekretär gerade aber zurück als
bekannt wurde dass die partei
gesprächstermine bei abendessen mit dem
damaligen ministerpräsidenten jürgen
rüttgers an unternehmen verkauft hatte
seit 2013 ist endres vorsitzender der
cdu-mittelstandsvereinigung nrw seit
2017 verkehrsminister jetzt solle
parteivorsitzender und ministerpräsident
werden
es gibt aufgaben so gemacht werden muss
und das ist glaube ich das was hendrik
wüst besonders auszeichnet er steht auch
für das gute miteinander von jung und
alt von
rheinland und westfalen in zwei wochen
soll der landesparteitag hendrik wüst
zum vorsitzenden wählen im landtag steht
dann die wahl zum ministerpräsidenten an
abweichler kann sich die koalition aus
cdu und fdp nicht erlauben denn schwarz
gelb regiert in düsseldorf nur mit einer
stimme mehrheit
große ehre für die deutsche forschung
zum zweiten mal hintereinander bekommt
ein deutscher den nobelpreis für physik
dieses mal für bahnbrechende
klimamodelle klaus hassel man teilt sich
eine hälfte des preises mit dem us
amerikanische kugelmann aber die andere
hälfte geht an den italiener giorgio
parisi schon vor jahrzehnten haben diese
forscher bewiesen dass der mensch für
den klimawandel verantwortlich ist
volker dutschek
professor klaus hasselmann ist auch mit
89 immer noch auf dem neuesten stand
fachliteratur auf englisch und deutsch
vor allem in sachen klimaforschung am
vormittag klingelte plötzlich sein
telefon ich möchte meine anrufe ungefähr
eine stunde durch war das
war ganz überrascht dachte ich träume
aber
scheint zu stimmen dieser hatte und so
wird es wohl stimmen am hamburger max
planck institut für meteorologie
entwickelte hass wenn man eine methode
die zeigte wie menschen gemachte
treibhausgase wie kohlendioxid und fckw
das land und das mehr aufheizte er und
sein team rechneten in modellen vor dass
die erwärmung der erde schon mitte der
90er jahre nicht mehr mit natürlichen
ursachen zu erklären war hasselmann war
der doktorvater von vielen jungen
wissenschaftlern auch von professor
mojib latif
lasse man halt zusammen mit dem zwei
nobelpreisträger manawi die moderne
klimaforschung begründet sie haben die
modelle so weit nach vorne gebracht dass
sie auch für fragen der globalen
erwärmung anwendung finden konnten und
der hat letzten endes die methodik
entwickelt wie man den menschen als
verursacher der globalen erwärmung
entlarvt wurde
großes hallo am abend in seinem alten
institut bei aller freude über den preis
weiß hasselmann das thema klima krise
braucht einen langen atem
[Applaus]
lange mit großer intensität und geduld
das ist den menschen etwas fremd und das
ist wichtig dass wir das lernen und ich
hoffe dass das lernen hat das durch
diesen preis es auch etwas mehr ins
bewusstsein der menschen kommt
das nobelpreis-komitee bezeichnete die
arbeiten von hasselmann manabe und
parisi als den grundstein unseres
wissens über das erdklima und den
einfluss des menschen darauf drei
physiker die quasi zur ahnengalerie der
friday is for future generation gehören
jetzt der blick auf die korona zahlen
das robert koch institut meldet
4799 neue infektionen innerhalb eines
tages das sind 628 mehr als vor einer
woche die sieben tage incident sinkt
leicht auf
63,6
psychische probleme bei jugendlichen
dazu hat das kinderhilfswerk unicef
alarmierende zahlen veröffentlicht jedes
jahr nehmen sich weltweit rund 46.000
junge menschen das leben im schnitt ein
suizid alle elf minuten und corona
trifft die jungen noch zusätzlich wegen
der pandemie fühlt sich jeder fünfte
mensch zwischen 15 und 24 jahren häufig
deprimiert und antriebslos in
deutschland sogar jeder vierte
hilfsangebote gibt es laut unicef viel
zu wenig
die eu finanzminister sprachen heute
über ein thema das vielen sorge bereitet
die steigenden energiepreise
der gaspreis zum beispiel ist steil nach
oben gegangen seit jahresbeginn hat er
sich mehr als verdoppelt wie kann wie
soll die eu gegensteuern florian neumann
hat mehr dazu in ihrem eigenen land hat
frankreichs regierung gerade den
gaspreis für ein halbes jahr gedeckelt
jetzt verlangt der finanzminister dass
europa insgesamt handelt der gaspreis
sie wissen dass der gaspreis in den
letzten wochen massiv ja brutal
angestiegen ist das macht uns allen
große sorgen
mathe aufhielt und schirm vorderes doch
schon in der analyse unterscheiden sich
die regierungen fällt der gaspreis bald
wieder oder können sich verbraucher auf
lange sicht kein gas mehr leisten vor
allem südeuropäer stehen unter großem
druck ihrer bevölkerung
sie schlagen vor dass europa eine
strategische gasreserve anlegt so kann
europa mit einer stimme sprechen wenn es
mit internationale zulieferer waren
unklar ob dieser vorschlag eine mehrheit
findet genau wie jena den frankreich mit
neuer vehemenz auf den tisch bringt die
verschwendung im kampf gegen den
klimawandel erfolgreich sein wollen dann
brauchen wir kernenergie wir müssen mehr
in atomkraftwerke investieren in lukla
in der deutsche noch finanzminister olaf
scholz lässt sich in luxemburg heute
vertreten die antwort auf die atomfrage
liefern andere wenn französische politik
großen wert darauf legt dass
strom co2 frei erzeugt ist wollen die
immer nur ein geschäft machen für
electricite de france für atomenergie
was tun gegen hohe gaspreise jetzt
wartet europa auf einen vorschlag der
eu-kommission
angekündigt für nächste woche
wichtiges eu treffen auch heute abend in
slowenien die staats und regierungschefs
beraten über europas rolle in der welt
es geht um die frage wie die eu mehr
eigenständigkeit entwickeln kann
insbesondere nach den jüngsten
alleingänge der usa beim abzug aus
afghanistan etwa hatten sich europäische
regierungen überrumpelt geführt
weltweit gibt es enthüllungen zum
sexuellen missbrauch durch katholische
priester nun hat eine unabhängige
untersuchungskommission bedrückende
zahlen für frankreich vorgelegt danach
wird dort die zahl minderjähriger opfer
seit 1950 auf
216.000 geschätzt die experten gehen von
rund 3000 tätern aus der papst reagierte
mit schmerz und bedauern und dankte den
opfern für ihren mut taten anzuzeigen
der internetgigant facebook gerät gerade
massiv in die bredouille
da ist zum einen die selbstverschuldete
technikpanne von gestern sechs stunden
lang ging gar nichts bei facebook
whatsapp und instagram milliarden kunden
weltweit waren betroffen aber weit
schlimmer für facebook dürfte sein was
diese ehemalige mitarbeiterin der welt
mitzuteilen hat im kern sagt die wissen
bloß in facebook spalte die gesellschaft
und verursache gewalt der konzern wisse
um die schäden habe sich aber immer für
das entschieden was mehr geld bringen
hohn und spott im internet ausnahmsweise
mal nicht auf sondern über facebook so
twittert das israelische militär
scherzhaft wenn ihr technischen support
braucht wir helfen gerne der
stundenlange ausfall von facebook
whatsapp und instagram eine katastrophe
für den perfektionisten zuckerberg und
doch nicht sein größtes problem im
moment
vor wenigen stunden anhörung im
senatsausschuss
die ehemalige facebook mitarbeiterin
francis horgen hat zehntausende interner
dokumente ausgewertet ihr vorwurf der
konzern denke nur an sich schade der
gesellschaft
die verantwortlichen wissen genau wie
sie facebook und instagram sicherer
machen könnten aber sie tun es nicht
denn ihr astronomischer profit ist ihnen
wichtiger als die menschen solange
facebook weiter im schatten agieren da
wird man sie nicht zur verantwortung
ziehen können
die whistleblower in möchte erreichen
dass der wohl gehütete algorithmus
angepasst und transparenter wird
außerdem solle man endlich konsequent
gegen hass und falschinformation
vorgehen das unternehmen stelle profit
über alles facebook sicherheitschef in
weiß das von sich
das stimmt nicht und widerspricht den
fakten seit 2016 haben wir 13 milliarden
dollar im bereich sicherheit und schutz
unserer nutzer investiert wir haben
40.000 mitarbeiter die sich nur damit
beschäftigen
große zahlen die er hofft sich mark
zuckerberg auch von seinem neuesten
projekt facebook horizon ein virtueller
ort der nutzerinnen und nutzer noch
stärker bahnen und beeinflussen sollen
der 37-jährige arbeitet weiter an seiner
vorstellung einer schönen neuen welt und
milliarden machen mit
welche folgen hat der stundenlange
totalausfall bei facebook für die nutzer
und was sagt das unternehmen zu den
vorwürfen der ehemaligen mitarbeiterin
weitere berichte und analysen finden sie
in der zdf heute
auf der kanaren insel la palma ist der
vulkan immer noch sehr aktiv knapp zwei
wochen nach seinem ausbruch ist der
krater zu einem großen teil eingestürzt
der strom glühender lava der zum meer
fließt ist mit 1300 metern jetzt
deutlich breiter außerdem erschütterten
erdstöße die insel
jetzt bist du dran wo die mit fußball
genauer länderspielwoche fußball
bundestrainer hansi flick bereitet seit
heute seine mannschaft auf die beiden wm
qualifikationsspiele ford freitag in
hamburg gegen rumänien und drei tage
später in nord mazedonien beim ersten
training fehlte nur manuel neuer aus
regenerationsgründen
hansi flick kann bei seinem zweiten
lehrgang als bundestrainer wieder auf
ein trio setzen dass bei den september
länderspielen nicht zum einsatz kam so
sind torwart marc andré ter stegen
innenverteidiger mathias ginter und
torjäger thomas müller zurück im kader
im idealfall ist die dfb auswahl mit
zwei siegen vorzeitig für die wm
endrunde qualifiziert das ist natürlich
unser aller ziel gerade mit den spielen
jetzt mit den quali-spielen dort uns so
schnell wie möglich zu qualifizieren und
natürlich auch für mich persönlich
dass ich zu dieser zeit in einem jahr in
einer verfassung sein werde da sie auf
diesem niveau der mannschaft sowohl in
meinem verein oberbayern als auch der
nationalmannschaft da helfen kann sie
wollen den positiven trend bestätigen
nach drei siegen in serie ohne ein
einziges gegentor herrscht so etwas wie
eine zarte aufbruchstimmung doch die
ganz großen herausforderungen kommen mir
erst noch
auch für den neuen u 21 bundestrainer
antonio di salvo steht am donnerstag die
erste bewährungsprobe an da muss seine
mannschaft in der em quali in paderborn
gegen israel antreten die messlatte
hängt hoch unter vorgänger stefan kunz
war das nachwuchs team europameister
geworden
noch ist die weste weiß doch gleich bei
des albums dfb cheftrainer debüt am
donnerstag wird ist die gegnerische
mannschaft in sich haben jetzt kommen
mit israel direkten gegner der in ungarn
und in polen gewonnen hat wir wissen
dass es eine herausforderung wird als co
trainer hilft hermann gerland zuletzt
lange jahre in dieser rolle bei bayern
münchen zu sehen dass immense wissen des
67 jährigen soll das q1 und 20 projekt
bereichern wird eine große hilfe sein
zum einen natürlich für das trainerteam
mit seiner erfahrung aber ganz ganz
sicher auch für die spieler diese
kleinen tipps tier der hat der spielort
paderborn ist bestens ausgesucht es ist
die geburtsstadt von antonio di salvo
das war der kompakte sportler waren
dankeschön zum schluss noch eine
premiere erstmals wird dort einen
spielfilm gedreht für die russische
schauspielerin julia perez elbe und
ihren regisseur ging es heute nach
wochenlangem training los mit der sojus
kapsel zur iss vor zwei stunden kamen
sie an und sollen zwölf tage auf der
raumstation bleiben das ganze ist für
russland ein prestige-erfolg war man
doch schneller als hollywood mit tom
cruise der auch auf die reise
ungemütlich wird das wetter morgen mit
schauern und einzelnen gewittern die
details hat gleich aus dem terry
christian sievers begrüßt sie um viertel
vor zehn im heute journal
wir danken für ihr interesse und
wünschen noch einen schönen
dienstagabend bis morgen wenn sie mögen
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
und schon guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter weiterhin bestimmt
tiefer luftdruck das wetter in
deutschland das tief über dem norden
deutschlands über der nordsee teilweise
zieht auch weiter nach norden mit seinem
kern ansonsten gibts hier dieses tief im
süden das verlagert sich auch südwärts
und bringt vor allem an den alpen viel
regen ja und von westen her dehnt sich
dieses hoch hier richtung osten außen
verbindet sich dann mit dem hoch über
russland in den nächsten tagen und so
wird es allmählich ruhiger und sonniger
soviel zur großwetterlage in der nacht
gibt es schauer im norden ist es
teilweise trocken bei tiefstwerten mit
sechs grad an den alpen und zwölf grad
nach osten hin morgen im tagesverlauf
schauer und gewitter auch im westen
möglich nach süden teilweise kräftige
schauer und im osten ist es etwas
trockener teils mit sonnigen abschnitten
bis 17 grad dort und 10 grad am
alpenrand
die nächsten tage werden allmählich
ruhiger am donnerstag im süden noch
regen mit dichten wolken sonst aber
schon trocken bei 10 bis 18 grad ab
freitag nebel und danach auch häufig
sonnenschein temperaturen 12 bis 19 grad
ein schöner abend